hey guys it's vadim with max tech and in
this video
we are gonna answer one of the most
difficult questions in the apple world
of tech
right now do you buy the m1 ipad pro
potentially with the magic keyboard
or do you just go with the m1 macbook
air because they have the same chip but
they are
totally different as you guys are going
to see in this video because we're going
to be comparing everything
between the keyboards the track pads the
displays the touchscreen support apple
pencil support
performance app support file management
everything in this video and give you
guys an answer
on which one you should buy so let's get
right into it
as you guys probably already know we
love the m1 macbook air because it gives
you the best bang for the buck
in terms of the value and performance
because you can get it
for only a thousand dollars or 950 on
amazon
on sale if you use the link below so
it's an excellent deal
but with the ipad pro now that we have
the m1 chip
this is also a great setup especially
with the magic keyboard case
which we absolutely love and i'd say if
you're getting this ipad pro
it deserves the magic keyboard because
it is just so
excellent as i'm going to show you guys
in just a minute and of course you also
have the touchscreen support with the
apple pencil
the only issue is that this 12.9 inch
setup right here
costs a total of fifteen hundred and
fifty dollars
or 1650 if you get the same 256 gigs of
storage
as the m1 macbook air and that is very
expensive so we're gonna answer in this
video if it's worth spending that much
money now of course you could just go
with the tablet itself which is eleven
hundred dollars
but this video is meant to be kind of
like a laptop setup comparison
so we're going to be focusing on that
and if you really do want to save some
money
you can just go with the 11 inch ipad
pro setup which is significantly cheaper
because you have 800
for the ipad pro only 300 instead of 350
for the magic keyboard case
and the apple pencil so it's not going
to be as expensive as this one
and this is arguably more portable
because as you can see
it's much smaller in terms of the
footprint compared to the 12.9
but because in our last video a lot of
you guys wanted us to use the 12.9 inch
to compare to the macbook air instead so
we're going to be doing that in this
video both the macbook air and the ipad
pro have a really
really nice all aluminum design but one
of the main differences you can see
is that the ipad pro has rear cameras
which you cannot get on the macbook air
and i don't know how big of a deal that
is for you
but there's also the lidar scanner the
flash so there's the extra features that
you can't get on the macbook air and
without the magic keyboard case the ipad
pro is obviously
much slimmer more compact but
interestingly it
is slightly wider on this end and that's
because the aspect ratio is different
but on the long end it is quite a bit
less wide so that is nice and i'd say
because of that extra thinness it is
pretty portable by itself
but then when you add on the magic
keyboard case the ipad pro setup
actually weighs more weighs three pounds
compared to 2.8 on the macbook air
and then it does get quite a bit more
bulky it does get a little bit thicker
because it doesn't have that taper down
like the macbook air does so it is
thicker
and on top of that it is wider as well
because of the hinge
that's built into the magic keyboard
case and i've got to say guys
i absolutely love the new white color
option on the magic keyboard case
it looks so so good and on top of that
i think the black option kind of gets
like fingerprints
and scuffs easier so i think the white
is going to look much cleaner long-term
as well
and my absolute favorite part is this
open it up like that
boom you have a floating ipad design
with that hinge take it off with one
hand
put it back on it's amazing i love it
now moving on to authentication
the m1 macbook air has the touch id
button right here in the corner
works just like that nice and easy but
i love the ipad pro because it has face
id and with the magic keyboard you
simply just
double tap the space bar boom locks you
in instantly you don't have to reach
anywhere
it's just done and the reason i love the
magic keyboard so much other than the
obvious
floating ipad pro design is the trackpad
it is so responsive it's super nice it's
better than
any other keyboard case out there it is
literally the best because it does not
have a diving board design you have an
even clicking feel
all around the trackpad just like we've
always had
on the macbooks like it's the best the
only difference is that the macbook
comes with kind of
forced touch so if you kind of like
double double press you get like menus
like that
whereas the ipad pro cannot do that it's
just one click so you have to kind of
click
and hold to bring up menus like this but
this trackpad is
amazing the only thing i don't really
like about it is that it's kind of
slim compared to the macbook air which
has a much wider
or much taller trackpad but in reality
it's just enough for what you need for
doing like gestures like that
swiping side to side switching between
apps
works really well and another thing i
love is the
keyboard the keys themselves they are so
good
honestly i feel like the keys on the
magic keyboard case
are better than the ones on the macbook
air i know they're very similar but
one thing's for sure these keys are
better than
any other keyboard case out there that's
another reason why i tell people
to buy the magic keyboard case even
though it's super expensive
you're not going to regret it once you
kind of cough up that money
it's very expensive but it's it's worth
it it's definitely worth it the only
issue is that you do not have the top
row of function keys
like we have on the macbook air with all
these brightness controls audio
everything else you don't have those
with the magic keyboard case
unfortunately
but because it's just so good and it's a
tablet i can live without it and now
with all that said in our previous ipad
pro comparisons we noticed that the 12.9
inch ipad pro
sounds better and louder than the 11
inch version
which is really nice but how does it
compare to
the macbook air let's find out
[Music]
oh my goodness that was a huge
difference i was not expecting that
because i'm used to hearing the 11 inch
ipad pro speakers but man
the ipad pro the 12.9 inch sounds insane
it was louder the highs and the vocals
were more clear
the mids were louder they had more bass
everything all around is better on the
ipad pro
compared to the macbook air which kind
of sounded muted it was kind of more
leaned towards the highs but even then
it just wasn't balanced and that bass
was totally lacking
the ipad pro speakers man they are good
now let's go ahead and move on to the
ports but there's one thing that i
forgot to mention in terms of these
keyboards and kind of like the laptop
experience
i noticed that the magic keyboard case
with the ipad pro
isn't as good or convenient on your lap
compared to the macbook air which is a
much better
lap experience so the ipad pro is more
for kind of like this
setup with a tabletop as far as the
ports the first thing i want to mention
is that the macbook air has a headphone
jack
over here on the side which the ipad pro
unfortunately does not have
and the air also has two thunderbolt
ports right here that can also be used
for usb
4 while the ipad pro now finally has a
thunderbolt port right
here but it's just one but if you get
the magic keyboard case you actually get
a
charging port built into the hinge which
is very convenient because you can
charge using
this one right here and what we noticed
with that built-in charging port is that
it charges the ipad pro
basically at the same speed as the
regular port
and then if you're using that you have
this freed up for whatever else like
thunderbolt accessories
except there is just one issue and let
me show you guys
this right here is a treble eat
thunderbolt 3 ssd
and when you plug it in it does not show
up in the files
app like it should i don't know why
but hopefully with ipad os 15 coming up
that issue is gonna get fixed and now
let's finally get into the absolute
biggest difference between these two and
that is of course
the touchscreen support which you do not
have
on the macbook air no macbooks have had
that before so
if you really care about the touch
experience you've got to go
with the ipad pro and of course that
also goes along with the apple pencil
so as you can see there you go i'm in
the notes app obviously this is the best
use case because if you're an artist you
have those professional apps that you
use
so this by itself is going to be a deal
breaker for some people out there
because you can't
use the apple pencil with a mac unless
you get a different ipad with like
sidekick
or whatever else this is a major major
selling point that's going to make
all of the difference now the next thing
i want to get into is the
webcam so with the macbook air you have
a 720p webcam
and because of the m1 isp it actually
looks pretty good
now on the ipad pro it has a brand new
12 megapixel ultra wide which basically
gives you
1080p check this out when i switch to
ultrawide mode
boom look at that view that you get it's
actually
really nice and the quality of this is
really really impressive the only issue
with the ipad pro
is that when you're looking down at the
center of the display you can tell that
you are not
looking at the camera i wish it was
right here like on the macbook but it's
not so especially when you're zoomed in
like look at that that perspective is
just kind of weird you're like looking
off to the side but apple did something
very cool with this ipad pro and that's
the center stage feature
so when you're using facetime or
something else like maybe zoom
when you go side to side the camera
follows your face
and it tries to keep you kind of
centered which is really really cool
and it helps keep the experience when
using facetime a lot better
and now let's go ahead and test the
microphone quality this is the
m1 macbook air and now let's switch over
to the ipad
and now this is the studio quality
microphones on the ipad pro as you can
tell this is a little bit weird so i
have to kind of go off to the side
and then look at the webcam if you want
like a perfect kind of uh
angle which is weird but let me know how
the microphone quality is down in the
comment section below
and now let's finally move on to the
display quality comparison
and this new ipad pro the 12.9 inch
model gets the
brand new mini led display which is
insane because it can go up to 1600 nits
of brightness for hdr content
but that's only for hdr when you're just
using it like a regular ipad
it's limited to 600 nits but that's
still
a lot brighter than the macbook air's
400 nits so it's going to be nice for
those bright environments
and especially if you're going outside
but the most important part about mini
led is that there are over 10
000 of those mini leds and they have
local dimming zones
so right here in this image only the
leds
right here behind this coke bottle are
on so basically it gives you
pure blacks so instead of having grays
all around
the macbook air because the panel in the
back it lights up the entire display at
once
so you kind of have those grays you have
pure blacks on the ipad pro so let me
play this
and show you guys the difference first
of all you can tell that the ipad pro
is quite a bit brighter which is really
really nice
and i can definitely see that the
contrast
isn't as good on that macbook air
everything's slightly gray
but on the ipad pro oh my goodness those
little bubbles
pop like crazy the color is more kind of
vibrant those highlight details
everything
whoa guys this looks so dim like it's
all kind of flat but
man those highlights are popping like
crazy that looks really good
now one of the issues with the mini led
display is a little bit of blooming
now i think it's a little bit over
exaggerated and i feel like there's some
kind of software issues that it's making
blooming
worse than it should be but right now in
this kind of
brightly lit medium lit environment you
don't really notice it
even in this shot where you have pure
blacks and very
bright glowing bulb oh my goodness the
difference between these two
it is insane like wow this display
is so much better like it's not as
bright on the macbook air
the colors don't pop the detail doesn't
pop right there that is insane just
everything is kind of muted on the
macbook air
apple you guys did a killer job now the
last thing i want to mention is that
even if you're not watching
hdr content like this which ipad you
should buy video that we just posted by
the way definitely check it out
one thing that has always bugged me with
the displays
on macbooks is the gray bars
above and below the image as you can see
right here
they are gray but on the ipad pro these
bars
are completely black and that is a huge
difference in kind of experience and
quality of life it just looks so much
better
having those black bars actually be
black
and that is a huge deal for me because i
watch movies on my 15 inch macbook pro
at home and with all the lights off it
sucks
seeing those gray bars oh and one thing
i just noticed
is the keyboard backlighting on the
white keys people said that you wouldn't
be able to see it
but they definitely help in this dark
environment and the cool thing is that
they're
automatic they're based on the ambient
light sensor on the ipad pro
so when it gets dark those backlighting
keys
turn on just like they do with the
macbook air now before we get into the
performance comparison
i want to mention one of the major
differences between these two
and that is of course the app support
with the ipad pro
you're limited to whatever is on the ios
app store
and that's it but with the macbook you
have access to the
professional apps like final cut all the
other apps davinci resolve
just a major major variety of apps
anything that you download
from the web you can use on the macbook
air which you cannot do on the ipad pro
and you can even get parallel 16 and get
windows 10
on here and use a lot of windows apps or
windows games
you can't do that on the ipad that's a
major difference and some people are
going to be choosing the macbook
just for that reason and to make it even
better for the macbook
with that new m1 chip check this out you
can go and download
iphone and ipad apps right here so you
get the extra advantage of
having access to those apps but the
issue is right now
that app support isn't that great on the
macbook air hopefully apple's gonna fix
it but you don't have
everything that you want like the best
most popular games
you can't get on the m1 macbook air
however
2021 is coming up really soon and there
is a good chance that apple is going to
be announcing
professional mac apps coming to the ipad
pro
but we don't know just yet how good it's
going to be and there's a good chance
that the full
version on the macbook is going to be
better or more feature loaded
but who knows maybe apple's going to
surprise us
and now let's finally get into the
absolute biggest difference between
these two
which is going to make or break your
decision to go with the ipad pro
or the macbook and that is the file
management which is not good on the ipad
pro
of course we have the new files app but
it sucks
it's not that good it's kind of hard to
use it's not
full featured like on the macbook air
you have
everything everything you want desktop
documents it supports a lot of different
files which the ipad does not so file
management
killer killer on the macbook air
especially since the thunderbolt drives
work perfectly
whereas on the ipad pro right now
they're not working for some reason but
the one thing that keeps me
preferring the macbook experience over
the ipad
is of course the multitasking and split
screen
capabilities right here we have three
different
apps open we have a safari page another
one right here an activity monitor
and you can move these around whatever
way you like which is awesome
but on the ipad you're limited to just
two apps and
you can't really move them around
customize them however you want you can
split them up like this
but that's about it so the multitasking
is definitely
nowhere near as good on the ipad pro and
if you're someone who loves connecting
your computer to an external display
the macbook air is perfect for that you
get fully featured external display
support
but with the ipad it sucks you basically
hook up and you get like a mirror image
of the ipad it's not a good experience
you can't bring different apps over and
use multiple apps at the same time
it's just nowhere near as good and i
really hope apple is going to fix that
at wwdc but on the other hand
the one thing that macbooks do not have
is cellular support
and with the new m1 ipad pro you can get
5g connectivity so you don't have to
rely on wi-fi
when you're going out doing whatever
that is something that's really awesome
and convenient for a lot of people
and now let's finally get into the
performance comparison and one thing i
want to mention is that the m1 macbook
air the base model
only gets a 7 core gpu compared to 8 on
the ipad pro
and in reality it doesn't really make
that big of a difference
especially in the real world both of
these have 8 gigs of ram and they both
have the option to go up to 16
but i would say right now 16 is a waste
on the ipad pro
because as of right now apps are
currently limited to
around 5 gigs of ram only you can't go
higher
so you can't use the full potential of
the ipad pro with 16 gigs
until apple removes that limitation
hopefully with ipad os 15. but with that
said let's go ahead and run
the cpu geekbench 5 benchmark all right
we got our scores back and you can tell
that the macbook air
has a slightly higher single core score
maybe it's within a margin of error it
really should be because it's the same
chip but in terms of multi-core there's
around
400 points higher on the macbook air
that might be because
of a little bit of thermal throttling on
the ipad approach chassis
but i'm not sure but hey it's actually
really really close
and now let's run the metal graphics
test and there is the difference in
graphics performance as you can see
we're getting around 1500 more points on
the ipad pro
because of that eight core gpu compared
to seven cores so
there is a difference but in reality
it's not that big
and to test that let's go ahead and do
the 3dmark wildlife
benchmark i'm not sure why the ipad pro
is in this orientation but as you can
see we have wildlife
extreme unlimited on both of these so
let's go ahead and start it we have our
scores and it looks like the ipad pro
is getting around 12 more fps thanks to
that extra gpu core but one thing i know
for sure is that you guys do not want to
see
those synthetic benchmarks you guys want
to see real world
so what i have right here is lightroom
open on both the macbook air and the
ipad pro and i have
50 42 megapixel raw photos selected and
we're going to do
an export test so let's go ahead and
share
export as and i'm going to be matching
up the settings so we have jpeg
80 image quality go to more options i'm
going to turn on the output sharpening
to screen so it's
perfectly identical on both of these so
let's go ahead and export this and see
how long it takes
ready set go and interestingly
the ipad pro is actually faster which is
weird because the chassis is thinner
they're both obviously fanless but the
macbook air should be performing better
because first of all the chassis is
thicker and the display is separated so
the heat kind of gets pulled away from
it it doesn't add onto it compared to
the ipad pro
which has everything all in one so it
heats up more
or it theoretically should but as far as
this
it's actually faster right now oh i
don't know if you guys noticed that but
the display on the ipad pro
just dimmed down because it is getting
very hot
whereas the macbook air did not do that
but the ipad is
almost finished and it looks like
it is done there you go
three minutes and 24 seconds for the
ipad pro
and the macbook is still going that is
mind-blowing i don't know how apple
managed to pull off
putting this much performance into the
thin ipad pro
and there you go the macbook air finally
finished i cannot believe it took that
long but it took
five minutes and 57 seconds
compared to three minutes and 24 that's
two and a half minutes
longer it does not make any sense at all
because in geekbench
it was performing better in the
multi-core performance
test so the only way i can make sense of
this
is that ipad os is much more kind of
efficient and optimized
compared to mac os which has to support
a lot of different things at the same
time
so i've got to say i'm extremely
impressed with the m1 ipad pro and now
before we get into the conclusion i want
to talk a little bit about gaming
obviously the ipad pro is limited to
whatever is in the app store and that is
it and based on the performance it's
overkill for
every single game out there that's the
biggest issue right now
we're waiting for more high performance
games
but the cool thing about the macbook air
is that it also supports
some ipad in iphone games as well but
not the most popular ones
but the best part is that you get to
play a wide variety of
mac os games as well and on top of that
we were able to get windows on here
using different methods like parallel 16
or other methods and actually get decent
gaming performance
for other games like that and you could
even use special programs to play those
really old classic nintendo games
so you have a wide variety of options
with the macbook air
in terms of gaming compared to the ipad
pro which is a little bit limited and
the last thing i want to talk about
is the battery life because they both
have the same
m1 chip but the macbook air has a larger
battery
it's gonna get better battery life maybe
around three to five
hours better than the ipad pro which is
definitely a plus and it might change
this decision for some of you
and now let's finally answer the
original question
should you buy the ipad pro setup which
is more expensive
or go with the macbook air well
if you just want to use the ipad pro as
a tablet
then you could easily be fine with the
11 inch model
which is more portable and it's
definitely a lot cheaper
even if you pay for the apple pencil
you're going to be cheaper than
the m1 macbook air however if you really
want that full
laptop replacement experience you could
end up spending
up to 550 to 650 dollars
more for the ipad pro which is a lot of
money
and i'd say that if you care more about
saving money than getting the
touchscreen support
i would honestly just go for the macbook
air because you're really getting a lot
of bang for your buck
and you're getting the full app in file
management support
compared to the limited experience on
the ipad pro
which is definitely lacking in those
areas but if you're willing to make some
compromises
in terms of the file management in order
to gain the touchscreen support and the
apple pencil
and everything else then the ipad pro is
definitely a great option
especially because of that amazing mini
led display
and if you're an artist who uses that
apple pencil professionally or as a
hobby
i've got to say you're going to be
enjoying the ipad pro
much more because if you go for the
macbook air you're going to be lacking
that touch touchscreen support and you
might even regret that you didn't go for
the ipad pro because the experience
is just so good with that apple pencil
and if you're trying to save some money
right now
you could just buy the ipad pro itself
and then hold off on the magic keyboard
case until you
save up some extra cash and then you can
buy it in the future
which is nice so to sum up this entire
comparison in one sentence
if you want to save money and get
excellent file management and
multitasking support
buy the macbook air or if you really
care about having touchscreen support
the apple pencil and a better display
experience on the 12.9 inch model
then buy the ipad pro so there you guys
go hopefully you enjoyed this video and
if you did
click that circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video